it's february 24th 2022
russian forces crossed the border into
ukraine they're following orders from
president vladimir putin
people here were packing up trying to
leave
a war unfolds that may fundamentally
alter the global geopolitical order
all i've showed to the german chancellor
calls this putin's war he says the
bloodshed must stop
european states are forced to react
this absolutely is a quantum leap for
the european union because they had to
acknowledge that all their political
doctrines their ideologies and their
beliefs throughout the last 10 maybe
even 20 years were simply wrong
deutsche fella correspondents cover the
war from day one
this is their account
[Music]
february 24th 2022 is a day that will go
down in history as a turning point
in a televised speech shortly before 6
a.m in moscow russian president vladimir
putin announces what he calls a special
military operation in the eastern
donbass region of ukraine
whoever tries to interfere with us and
even more so to create threats for our
country
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate
and will lead you to such consequences
that you have never experienced in your
history
[Music]
just before i've been hearing once again
sirens blaring we have heard that quite
often today in fact for the very first
time shortly after the first explosion
hit here around 4 am or shortly after
vladimir putin declared
quote a military operation against
ukraine now that military operation
actually turns into a full-scale
invasion several rockets that hit
various cities
those cities under attack are not only
in the donbass region but also in other
areas
they include kakis odessa and the
capital kief
an invasion by land by air by sea that
is what is happening right on ukraine
and people here in kiev the ones who are
staying are hoping that uh maybe what we
have experienced this morning the
explosions the shelling that maybe this
is it but
if you ask me there have been so many
things happening over the course of the
past days that nobody thought is likely
[Music]
russian troops enter ukraine from the
east north and the south from russia
belarus and the crimean peninsula they
hit military targets and residential
areas
explosions are heard in many parts of
the country shellings and reports of
people being injured and killed no the
problem is we cannot verify this
information so i can only tell you in
fact what i've been experiencing this
morning and that was a very very
critical situation people here were
packing up trying to leave
desperate people trying to flee the
areas under attack
[Music]
we've been trying all day since this
morning but as you can see here it's
unrealistic
there's lots of us a dog we can't fit
we're going back
you have to push through but how are we
supposed to do that with a child
they leave any way they can away from
the bombed cities away from the
advancing russian troops
it's in fact almost impossible to go
towards the west so much traffic traffic
has built up again they're also people
who are just staying put and uh trying
to
inform themselves actually where is the
nearest shelter when those sirens are
going to go off again
but while the terror is working it soon
becomes clear that russia's assault is
not going as planned
[Music]
the attack on the ground stalls
they expected a blitzkrieg that would be
over in three days
but this is the second week already or
rather it's been longer than two weeks
they haven't achieved great military
success
the big cities are partly destroyed but
are not conquered and the ukrainians are
of course playing for time the longer
the war lasts the more weakened the
russian army becomes
pictures that we're seeing of tanks
russian tanks basically stranded on the
on the street meaning possible obviously
that they do run out of fuel just like
anyone else by the way right now so
the fact that we're seeing mostly rocket
attacks on the city at the moment
is an indication i think that um a
ground assault is proving more difficult
and is is not perhaps likely in the
immediate future
the russian army fires hundreds of
rockets on ukraine cities
and
people casualty numbers rise quickly
we spoke to military experts to identify
what kind of attack was happening here
and they told us that this is most
likely a cluster bomb now the only other
weapon it could have been uh would have
shown larger explosions closer to the
surface of the building now the problem
with cluster bombs is that they
indiscriminately uh
harm civilians and and enact devastation
especially in urban settings such as
this one and so
uh when when war crimes investigators
when they start seeing the use of
cluster bombs in a conflict it usually
signals a sign that you know there's
quite possibly war crimes being
committed here and in this case in
ukraine
[Music]
after the shock caused by the heavy
shelling of their cities
people get used to seeking shelter where
they can
[Music]
um most people here in cuba have spent
the night underground either in cellars
or airaid shelters for people who don't
have that the only option is the metro
which is pretty deep there have been
some pretty heart breaking images of
whole families camped out on
camping picnic blankets on the metro
platforms trying to distract their kids
just last night the expectation was that
there would be air raids around 3am
local time and then they didn't happen
for most of the night and just as the
curfew ended at 7am suddenly there's a
lot more activity and you could hear
thoughts in the background in the
distance even here on the ground so it's
basically this kind of sense of
paralysis
and then you're constantly kind of
looking at your phone
expecting some kind of warning and kind
of paralyzed by that
inability to really understand what's
going on
the attacks by the russian military
bring the horrors of war once more to
europe they trigger an exodus to
neighboring countries
except the men
men between 18 and 60 are not allowed to
leave
they have to stay to potentially defend
their country
it's very sad
it's very hard to let go of a loved one
because you know that it's hard there
there is military action and my father
could die at any moment
people have left kharkiv but it is very
difficult to get out of there under
constant shelling and
the
capacities are very limited of these
trains and
so um
there are quite a few places now where
suffering is really really big now
in an unexpected turnaround many
ordinary ukrainians resist
some by blocking roads with their bodies
others by taking up arms
and i have to say that i was totally in
or to speak with
those soldiers who used to be just two
weeks ago
they used to have just normal jobs and
now they are ready to give their lives
for their country and and i i've been
told by so many of them that they
believe that ukraine will prevail and
they believe that the evil evil as they
call russia and russian troops here in
ukraine that they cannot defeat the will
of the people to defend their country so
it's it's really impressive and and
almost so so difficult to come to terms
how their lives have changed uh over the
course of the last week that they have
to
they had to give out their their normal
lives and they're now ready to protect
their country
the ukrainian parliament approved a
draft law allowing all citizens to use
weapons to fight the russian attack
russians can enter keefe but they're not
going to leave again they're all going
to burn here
this is one of the roads that lead
directly into the territories that the
russian army is already occupying
and the people here are preparing for an
attack from that side
a tank can easily push away these
concrete blocks but these iron hedgehogs
as we call them cannot be pushed away
we'll have to get out of their tank to
clear the road
this will allow us to gain some time
that's what these things do
[Applause]
the ukrainian resistance unfolds on
different levels on the streets and
across all manner of social media
we've seen some pretty extraordinary
images on social media of protests going
on in spite of that russian military
occupation going on there people coming
out unarmed with flags getting up on
tanks demanding the return of their
elected officials
foreign
[Music]
leave think of your own children of your
mothers who must be crying
city bus just got hit by the rocket
lives are getting lost
that's the war
that russia started that's the city of
kiev
and many cities
in ukraine
were destroyed
lives
were taken
that's the truth
this images is the truth
of russian
war against ukraine president president
zielenski appeared in a video on social
media early this morning basically
trying to show i'm still here i'm not
going to lay down arms there are people
who want to resist that want to fight
and this is something that president
zelinski also underlined in his
appearances on social media that
everyone is really needed to
fight the russian troops
if you respected european leaders world
leaders leaders of the free world if you
do not help us today if you do not give
ukraine real help the war will knock on
your door tomorrow
glory to the ukrainian armed forces
glory to ukraine
ukraine
[Music]
the european union and nato are in the
middle of drastically reshaping their
policies
military defense
energy independence trade and geo
strategy
almost all areas of international
diplomacy are affected
we will invest more than two percent of
our gdp in defense every year from now
on
the german government really has done
has performed a 180 degree turn on its
policy
all i've showed to the german chancellor
calls this putin's war he says the
bloodshed must stop and he says there
can be no taboos anymore this must be
sanctioned this must be punished now of
course this is something where germany
was late and many people still criticize
that but this is also not just a ukraine
crisis is the message here from the
german government this is potentially
about defending something much bigger
about european values
for the first time ever
the european union will finance the
purchase and delivery of weapons and
other equipment
to a country that is under attack
it's not just weapons western countries
soon impose sanctions on russia
and consider taking another bigger step
we have to get rid of russian fossil
fuels as soon as possible it's it's a
very difficult situation that in one
hand we have these financial sanctions
that are very hard but in the other hand
we are supporting and actually financing
russia's war
purchasing oil gas and other fossil
fuels from russia so the situation is
isn't a very good one and we have to get
rid of the fossil fuels coming from
russia as soon as possible
this absolutely is a quantum leap for
the european union because they had to
acknowledge that all their political
doctrines their ideologies and their
beliefs throughout the last 10 maybe
even 20 years were simply wrong
russia and the west are strongly bound
by economic ties
russia has long been a major provider of
oil and gas to europe with some
countries very heavily reliant on these
imports for private consumption as well
as for the industrial sector
europe on the other hand is one of the
main suppliers of machinery vehicles and
technology that russia badly needs
cutting these ties is seen as the best
way to try to stop the war
today
in light of russia's reckless and
dangerous military strike
we're imposing
further
severe sanctions
today in concert with our allies we will
agree a massive package of economic
sanctions designed in time to hobble the
russian economy
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
the ban aims to weaken russia's economy
even more um rahila biden said that they
want to keep pressure on president putin
and
his war machine and president biden said
that he doesn't want to subsidize this
war um the thing is oil and gas exports
are the backbone of russia's economy and
the revenue of um this business of gas
and oil exports make half of the budget
of the kremlin so this should be painful
for russia and it will have an impact
that's what they hope on the money they
need to keep this war ongoing
but while the u.s bans russian oil and
gas some european countries like germany
and the netherlands hesitate their
citizens and industries depend heavily
on russian fossil fuels
the sanctions hit ordinary russians
quickly but some analysts doubt they'll
be enough to force vladimir putin to
stop the war in the short term
well let me say so that let me say that
in my view of course people who are
dealing with economic and financial
issues within the russian government
should
assess uh the implication of this
military operation
they should have a clear understanding
of sanctions and what sanctions might
mean for the russian economy
for the russian financial system but as
we hear from uh
vladimir putin
and other leaders in the russian
government they argue that sanctions are
unavoidable that it really doesn't
matter
what russia
can do or what it will not do sanctions
will be there
because the the west is hostile to
russia and uh it wants
russia to disappear from the map of the
world
russians are badly hit by inflation and
the freefall of the ruble
at the same time security forces try to
quash any form of protest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thousands across the country risk
publicly opposing the war in various
different ways
i'm ready to drop on my knees before
each ukrainian soldier please forgive us
this war is inexplicable
and people are dying on each side
russian and ukrainian
we are people who used to live amicably
in peace and in harmony now we are
separated
i don't understand this
[Music]
putin's government prohibits protests
against the actions of the armed forces
it even bans using the word war for the
invasion of ukraine
critical media and reporting are
suppressed
but they can't stop everyone's
i don't think uh it's going to change i
think it's going to get harder and
harder to get information and even you
know with this protest that we just saw
that poster that the woman was holding
up um various media outlets did report
about that but they actually had to blur
her poster and they were only uh allowed
to say that she
um you know protested for pacifism
essentially because they're not allowed
to use the word war and of course her
poster had the word war on it the
official line um on this war is that
it's a special operation where no
civilians are being targeted and um you
know i was saying it's going to get
harder and harder it already has gotten
harder and harder to read any critical
media outlets many have already been
blocked within russia many critical
journalists have had to leave the
country facebook and instagram have also
been blocked
getting independent information about
russian thinking is getting more
difficult by the day
russian opinion polls show a majority of
russians back their president and the
war
if you look at the opinion polls you'll
find out that
the majority of russians also support
actions of
the kremlin in ukraine because the
belief is that it's not a war against
ukraine and if you talk to russian
people in russia now somebody still
believe it's not a war it's just
military exercise
as russian forces expand their
devastation of ukrainian cities the war
sparks the biggest refugee crisis in
europe since world war ii
[Music]
here in european it's another attempt to
organize a humanitarian corridor
temporary ceasefire to allow civilians
to get out with their their pets their
children they can grab
you can definitely see other people
getting across this destroyed bridge
today but there is fighting going on
very close so you can see just
behind the bridge above those unfinished
houses plumes of smoke that's a couple
of clumps away
this is one of the places that had been
fought about for days people have been
sitting there trapped waiting for an
opportunity to get out
women and children try to get to safety
families are split apart
we left everything and just fled i don't
know whether we can ever come back
[Music]
i think the situation that stayed with
me the most was yesterday when we were
right at the border where the men have
to say goodbye to their wives because
man right now they can't leave ukraine
if they're between 18 and 60 years old
we met vladimir and this is what he told
us
what are you going to do now are you
going to go
i will go some
i brought probably territorial defense
or something like that
and we'll be preparing for the fight
ukraine's western borders littered with
heartbreak
at the crossings volunteers await the
fleeing ukrainians and offer them a
welcome and basic necessities
the children of ukraine are fleeing war
and are arriving here at this railway
station near the border
they bring with them the trauma of
upheaval fear and sometimes wars
[Music]
if there had been no war our houses
would have stood
my grandfather now sleeps with a gun
[Music]
sometimes there were sirens in the
evening the people hid all day in
cellars and bunkers
[Music]
beyond the human suffering in ukraine
and historic refugee flows into
neighboring countries
the consequences of the war ripple
further
around the world
[Music]
this is a crisis compounding on existing
global crises and we've already seen and
started to feel the impact
of this conflict and on the wheat market
prices have gone up to 40 to 50 percent
in the last few days i think countries
that are dependent on wheat imports are
starting to scramble to find different
ways to cover their needs um some of
these countries are extremely vulnerable
yemen imports around 22 percent of their
wheat from ukraine
lebanon around half their wheat imports
are coming is coming from ukraine
libya egypt tunisia so i think we will
see a big impact on the economies of
these countries
[Music]
in a joint declaration the international
monetary fund and the world bank warned
that lower income countries will be hit
the hardest by rising prices on global
markets caused by the war
for russia's economy many experts paint
a grim picture for the immediate future
as well
the european council president sean
michelle said that these sanctions would
be massive and that they would be
painful and by all indications
they will be because let's consider the
effects and the impact that these
sanctions will have on the ground it is
likely to be felt
by ordinary russians ordinary russians
just trying to get by
they will see prices of
goods around them going up but it is
expected that inflation will rise in the
country
businesses been small businesses in
russia might be impacted as the economy
is expected to go into recession because
of this
as the war continues escalation into a
wider conflict is still a threat
but nato rejects ukrainian calls for the
alliance to do more by imposing a no-fly
zone for example
and the secretary general made clear as
he has on previous occasions that this
is just not going to happen that in fact
no nato ally has an appetite to be
engaged in a war with russia which is
what would happen if it needed to
enforce a no-fly zone to close the
airspace over ukraine
at the same time russia is said to have
asked china for military and financial
aid a warning that on a global scale the
war in ukraine could lead to the
formation of new geopolitical block
building a threat that the united states
addressed immediately
the u.s made
it very very clear that the chinese are
watched really watched on how they
behave themselves what they do for
russia if russia is and russia
apparently does ask for military help
and for economic help
i think the united states made clear
that and with a let's say
use the term warning here that this is
not in the best interest of china to do
this because it would have um really the
consequences not just
for china from the us but also from the
european partners as well as other
allies and partners from the us around
the world and their business with china
the war creates economic and
geopolitical turbulence as well as
humanitarian catastrophe
nobody can say for sure where the world
is heading after the russian invasion of
ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
you